and then humans we're standing up so
we're kind of like this loose table
where it's like you got the energy like
the connection from the earth comes in
but then it starts rattling because it's
not getting out yeah baby
baby time for me to get moving right
here right now right here right now yeah
baby it's time for me to get moving
right here right now right here right
now
this water looks sick for crabs and
everybody bouncing up and down on that
cold Beach there's a lot of foam and a
lot of jellyfish and
[Music]
so then I wonder if maybe that's one of
the reasons why we started thinking
about having like gods and stuff like
that because before if the energy went
right back into the Earth and if we just
knew we were part of the same Source I
feel like maybe we're supposed to be on
four limbs